sie wollten immer schon eine partyband
sein
der dokumentarfilm zeichnet das stimmige
bild einer sympathisch regen truppe
gegründet aus der not in der idyllischen
ostschweizer provinz
mein sohn ihren sound es war natürlich
nichts los wir wollten unser holten hat
ein bisschen was gescheites machen
gescheitert hiess blazer deutsch singen
war eigentlich ganz wichtig englisch
sind langweilig zu viel pop gefühl um in
der schweizer enge zu versauern zu wenig
rock attitüde um ganz groß zu werden wie
die toten hosen
trotzdem deutschland empfing sie mit
offenen armen
hamburg war mitte der 90er jahre ein
leuchtturm hier gab es alternative
deutsche musik mit intelligenten texten
die so genannte hamburger schule auch
die ostschweizer fühlten sich gleich
daheim
es war uns klar dass wir jetzt welt
erobern
doch nichts war es mit dem zweiten
beatles stattdessen die große
ernüchterung alles rackern und touren
brachte auch jahre später den durchbruch
nicht
aber all das erreichte einfach so
hinschmeißen nein das war keine option
für die arrow lauten zum scheitern sind
sie einfach zu groß
nein